bonsoir claude blanchou et on merci
d'être avec nous alors le refus de la
chambre des lords
est ce que c'est vraiment un affront
pour le premier ministre britannique
howie sais c'est un affront puisque les
dealers dans leur sagesse 10 au premier
ministre conservateur britannique qu' il
n'est sans doute pas au courant que il
doit respecter les traités
internationaux et notamment le traité
qu'il assignait sur le wifi d'il ya un
an
or le projet de loi qu'il a soumis à la
chambre dès lors est bien contrôlée
contrevient contredit sur au moins un
point très important au traité qui a été
signé l'année dernière et ce point très
important puisque c'est la liberté
totale de circulation sans frontières
entre les deuxième langue
alors c'est aussi un revers parce que la
position de la chambre des lords
affaibli la position de boris johnson
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne dans la
négociation qui est en cours
d'abord l'union européenne a déjà formé
un recours contre le projet de loi
puisque boris johnson refuse de le
modifier
et puis ensuite le ministre des affaires
étrangères d'irlande a dit tout haut
hier ce que beaucoup de gens pensent
tout bas à savoir à quoi bon à quoi bon
négocier un nouveau traité sur le futur
régime
si le toute façon gouvernement
britannique ne respectent pas le traité
signé l'année dernière donc on en est là
crise de confiance en réalité très
importante entre la grande bretagne et
l'union européenne
alors claude que veut vraiment obtenir
boris johnson dans ces négociations
en bas c'est assez simple dans les zones
sonne il veut obtenir le libre échange
entre la grande bretagne et l'union
européenne avec les inconvénients que
votre sujet vient de démontrer parce que
ce qu'il veut c'est un lieu de 1 libre
échange inconditionnel un libre échange
à l'ancienne comme dans les années 50
or ce que veut l'union européenne c'est
s'il ya un libre-échange évidemment que
ce soit dans des conditions de
concurrence équitables et que les normes
du marché européen soit respectée
puisque d'ailleurs les britanniques les
respecte on voit pas pourquoi il se
permettrait dans les années à venir de
baisser le niveau d'exigence en matière
environnementale soit en matière sociale
soit même en ce qui concerne les
subventions mais pour le moment les
britanniques refusent de s'engager dans
cette voie
ils veulent être totalement libre de
modifier leur législation interne comme
ils l'entendent
le l'autre point c'est que l'union
européenne dit à boris johnson de toute
façon une fois qu'on sera mis d'accord
sur le respect des normes européennes
eh bien il faut bien comprendre que
l'accès à ce marché très très très grand
très important suppose une contrepartie
qui nous paraît bien normal c'est que
nos pêcheurs puissent continuer à
accéder aux zones de pêche
traditionnelle dans les eaux
britanniques d'ailleurs l'épaisseur en
accédant à une condition aux eaux des
pays membres de l'union européenne
et là dans les zones sonne dit pas
question souveraineté britannique
nous négocierons par exemple chaque
année ou tous les deux ans tué trois ans
et faisons comme je viens de le
r avec la norvège et extérieurs à
l'union européenne un accord de deux ans
donc très précaires et pour lequel on
négocie chaque année les quotas de pêche
pour chaque espèce halieutiques pour
chaque espèce de poisson ah non on est
bien loin d'un accord et effectivement
ben on va voir ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours
mais justement que blanchemaison vous
dites on est bien loin d'un accord à ce
que l'échec des discussions devient de
plus en plus inéluctable selon vous igné
wee aa dérouler les arguments que je
viens d'avancé l'échec est relativement
probable cela dit cela dit la plupart
des décideurs économiques et politiques
dans les grandes capitales européennes à
londres comme à paris comme à berlin et
ailleurs sont tout à fait conscients de
l'énorme désordre économique
administratif qui s'installera à partir
du mois de janvier
s'il n'y a pas d'accord ça veut dire des
milliers de camions qui font la queue
dans la région de calais et dans la dans
le comté du kent en grande bretagne en
attendant que les formalités douanières
soit faite
ça veut dire peut-être des difficultés
d'approvisionnement agroalimentaire
notamment fruits et légumes mais aussi
en médicaments vos grands en royaume uni
qu'en bretagne
ça veut dire aussi des désordres sociaux
dans les ports dans les ports grand de
grande bretagne comme dans les ports
français ça veut dire aussi sans doute
le risque de difficultés politiques
importantes entre l'irlande du nord et
le gouvernement britannique et des
risques aussi de renaissance des
conflits qu'il y a eu malheureusement
pendant très longtemps entre la
république d'irlande et le
le gouvernement britannique donc les
enjeux sont considérables alors il se
peut tout à fait que prenant conscience
de cela la semaine prochaine
eh bien les dirigeants des pays
européens et et boris johnson se
reprennent et qu'ils consacrent quelques
jours à négocier un accord ce qui est
possible s'il ya une prise de conscience
aujourd'hui le sujet n'est pas sous les
feux de l'actualité
personne n'en parle par conséquent il
n'y a pas de pression politique
et quand il n'y a pas de pression
politique et n'est possible des
négociations entre l'union européenne et
un pays tiers fusse-t-il là la grande
bretagne n'avance pas
donc actuellement si la situation reste
ce qu'elle est eh bien il n'y aura pas
d'accord s'il ya une prise de conscience
de l'aspect dramatique de la situation
il peut y avoir un accord à la fin de la
semaine prochaine mais au niveau des
chefs d'état le gouvernement en tout cas
un boris johnson doit se passer en ce
moment du soutien sans vous précieux
d'un certain donald trump occupé par
d'autres petits sont si joe biden
devrait logiquement être le nouveau
président des états unis à partir du 20
janvier 2021
quelles conséquences selon vous pour ce
break 6 pour boris johnson notamment
favorisé hudson n'a pas de chance parce
que d'ailleurs by day by day 'n' il ya
un énorme le bi irlandais aux états unis
est seul au but irlandais est très
présent au sénat d'ailleurs joe biden en
fait partie et effectivement sur le b
irlandais par la voix de joe biden a
fait savoir au mois de septembre qu' il
n'était absolument pas acceptable que
on prenne le risque avec un accord mal
ficelé ou pas d'accord du tout d'un
d'une renaissance des troubles en
irlande du nord et joe biden a dit très
clairement que si c'était le cas il
n'était pas question qu'il ya un accord
de libre échange entre les états unis et
le royaume grande bretagne ce qui
résoudrait l affaire des producteurs de
poulet dont vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure
merci beaucoup aux clauses blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france